who has the best live-action TV
superhero clan is it the DC arrowverse
or Marvel's defenders not all heroes
wear capes but this one's currently
sporting tights okay hey everyone
marquel is here on the show where we
match up movies TV actors and characters
and we're looking at all time
greatnesses you decide whose Universe is
better the DC Air bursts or Marvel's
defenders here's a breakdown of what
characters are in which universe in the
air reverse we have conveniently arrow
flash Supergirl and legends of tomorrow
on the other side of the ledger is
Marvel's the defenders featuring
daredevil Jessica Jones Luke Cage the
Punisher iron fist and the defenders as
a whole here's how it works
three rounds round number one is the
tomato meter round number two is the
best fight scenes round three best
superpowers and we'll do a wild-card
round you can't expect me to believe
that you don't want to know
once and for all who would win round
number one tomato meter people may just
assume that the defenders would blow the
arrow kids out of the water on the
tomato meter simply because of the
success of the MCU versus the DCU on the
big screen don't fall for that think
McFly think it's a very competitive
matchup here are the era verse taking
the higher average across all of their
shows for all seasons with an impressive
88% to Marvel's 77% however let's just
rip off the band-aid now yeah iron fist
if you take iron fist to seasons out of
there marble goes from seventy-seven
percent to eighty five point seven
percent the immortal iron fist living
weapon is still hungry dumbass and
daredevil ranks is the highest
individual program for any of these
shows there's been three seasons of it
and they averaged 91 percent that will
get you into an Ivy League school but
I'm impressed enough with the sheer
amount of shows and seasons that the
error verse has given us to favor them
in this round he gets 7 seasons for
arrow 5 for flash 4 for Supergirl and
legends of peace so iron fist even if I
forgot about your tomato meters course
which I'm not really I'm still going
with the arrow verse in this round
arrowverse gets the win
[Music]
round two best fight scenes here's where
marble comes to play when you use to
think of epic fight scenes you probably
go with some huge battle with tons of
people punching and kicking and biting
there's probably a horse involved
somewhere but then daredevil happen and
audiences realize that a small scale
does not equal a boring fight nay it
ratchets up the intensity and engages to
the ER to the point where we can't take
our eyes off the screen look I give my
propers to the arrow verse 4 completely
altering my view on how violent a show
on the CW could be well they have the
flash fighting a shark guy in the street
that's awesome but the Marvel shows led
by daredevil seem to be built on
intricately choreographed flawlessly
executed fight scenes that pair nicely
with the desperation the heroes and
villains are feeling on the mean streets
of NYC the hallway scene in season 1
that made me want to sign up for karate
lessons and then the staircase scene in
season 2 made me quit it's just it's too
much cardio the defenders take the rebbe
and now we're tied at one round of peace
nice ear if horns round three best
superpowers Matt Murdock has some nice
six sensibilities but he also lacks
sight which puts him right back to the
standard five senses Luke Cage is jacked
and he feels the most superhero we of
the bunch
although Iron Fist clearly stuck with
martial arts longer than I did Jessica
Jones and the Punisher they seem to
thrive on their own psyche and intuition
more than any actual powers but boy do
those arrowverse kids have some
wonderful toys arrow is deadly accurate
the flash runs faster than Secretariat
and Supergirl
she's Supergirl yeah who knew she alone
has cooler powers than anyone on the
Marvel sideline if she came to the
defenders universe the rest of them can
go home
continue practicing law we're done here
DC takes this round in a landslide
the wild-card round is best team ups now
look how is a handsome fellow like me
supposed to take two huge universes and
parse all that glory down to just one
wildcard round there's so many
possibilities we could have gone with
villains for sure kingpin cottonmouth
Alexandre how do you solve a problem
like Maria you pit them against
Prometheus zoom malice that's a battle
royale with cheese so both universes
have great villains but in this modern
era of comic book entertainment glory it
isn't enough to be an individual
superhero it's about who you can team up
with who do you crossover with and how
do you fight crime alongside a bunch of
your fellow heroes this wildcard round
is best team ups because Hollywood is
all about who you know and the error
verse knows they're fans they regularly
give them what they crave in terms of
crossover events team ups and cameo
appearances and it's pretty awesome do
they go to the well a little too often
maybe but there's a reason you go to the
well it's got water and hydration is
essential am I the only one that read
Tom Brady's book what are we talking
about oh yeah team ups Marvel is
competitive in this round based largely
on the strength of the Punisher and wait
for that I didn't say daredevil you did
I was gonna say Karen page now Karen
page is an essential part of this world
and she seems to get Frank Castle more
than anyone else they all combined with
Murdoch and Nelson to make a spectacular
daredevil season 2 but then the actual
defenders had their season and okay so
you're any waivers fun I actually like
the iron fist okay in that - and I
thought Luke Cage and Jessica Jones
together we're dynamite but I didn't
feel like we need more of these kids
teaming up by the end we like them as
loners is this thing by themselves like
I do in my apartment every weekend the
arrowverse keeps us engaged by new
exciting crossover events like flash vs.
arrow crisis on earth ex Elseworlds
and next year's crisis on Infinite
Earths it's just like Taco Bell they
think the same four ingredients but they
keep wowing us with new dishes yes the
arrowverse is just like Taco Bell and
that's why it's taking the wildcard
round so there you have it I surprised
myself by going with these
over marble but the hard data and my
questionable logic definitely favor the
arrowverse but it's not up to me oh
never up to me it's on you you're the
viewer now you can make your voice heard
so shot from the rooftop which universe
you think is better and then come inside
type that same answer that you shout it
is a comment below so we can keep track
of it let us know your take we'll be
back with the results on a future
episode till then
I'm Mark Ellis not about to have a
crossover event with a sandwich I'm
going to eat it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]